.
WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW AS
WELL.
SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER NOW.
>> Sean: AS ALWAYS, WELCOME TO
"HANNITY" BEER TONIGHT
, BOZO BETO O'ROURKE IS BACK AND
NOT DOING VERY WELL.
A LOT OF CUSS WORDS, WE WILL
PLAY THE TAPE BUT WE HAVE
SERIOUS NEWS TO BEGIN THE NIGHT.
>> Announcer: AMERICANS HELD
HOSTAGE BEHIND ENEMY LINES: DAY
59.
>> Sean: 359, AMERICAN ALLIES,
GREEN CARD HOLDERS COMPLETELY,
UTTERLY ABANDONED BY YOUR
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
HE HAS EVEN MENTIONED THESE
INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN IN OVER 40 DAYS.
HE'S TURNED THE PAGE, AS HE
SAYS, AND NOW THE BITE
ADMINISTRATION IS PLANNING TO
SEND MORE MONEY TO THE
PROFESSIONAL AND BUSINESS LIKE
TALIBAN TERRORISTS.
THEY ARE CALLING IT HUMANITARIAN
AID BUT IN REALITY WHERE I GREW
UP, THAT LOOKS AN AWFUL LOT LIKE
A MASSIVE RANSOM PAYMENT TO
TERRORISTS.
TONIGHT IT IS CLEAR EVERYTHING
BIDEN TOUCHES BECOMES AN
UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
I CAN'T CITE A SINGLE SUCCESS.
AFGHANISTAN IS A HUGE MASSIVE
CRISIS, UNPRECEDENTED.
I'VE NEVER SEEN OR THOUGHT I
WOULD SEE THIS IN MY LIFE.
LOOK AT THE BORDER, ANOTHER
CATASTROPHE.
COVID-19 IS NOW WORSE UNDER
BIDEN DESPITE BEING GIFTED THREE
VACCINES, VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM, WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THERAPEUTICS, MONOCHROME
ALL ANTIBODIES AMONG THEM.
THE ECONOMY IS NOW COMPLETE AND
UTTER TRAIN WRECK.
A LOT OF DETAILS WE WILL GIVE
YOU, ESPECIALLY LOW AND MIDDLE
CLASS, MIDDLE INCOME AMERICANS.
INFLATION SHORTAGES,
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE WILL DETAIL ALL THE LATEST
TROUBLING STATISTICS.
IT'S CHILLING, ACTUALLY, AND
PERHAPS WORST OF ALL, JOE GAVE
INTO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
EXTREMISTS AND ABANDON THE
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE THAT
DONALD TRUMP HANDED HIM AND NOW
ALL OF US, ALL OF YOU ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE OF IT.
POLICE, HEALTH CARE WORKERS,
FIRST RESPONDERS, TEACHERS, MANY
ARE NOW BEING FORCED OUT OF
THEIR JOBS.
THEY ARE LEAVING IN THE MIDDLE
OF AN EMPLOYMENT SHORTAGE, ALL
BECAUSE OF JOE'S VACCINES
MANDATES.
I THOUGHT IF WE GOT THE VACCINE
WE PROTECTED OURSELVES.
APPARENTLY LIKE WITH ANYTHING
ELSE COVID RELATED, WITH BIOTIN
AND FAUCI -- THREE NEW POLLS
SHOW JOE BIDEN UNDERWATER BY
DOUBLE DIGITS.
HIS SUPPORT AMONG INDEPENDENTS
HAS NOW CRATERED TO JUST 37%.
AND NOW ANTI-BIDEN CHANTS ARE
BREAKING OUT IN STADIUMS AND
SPORTING EVENTS.
TALLADEGA, AT THE RYDER CUP,
FOOTBALL GAMES NATIONWIDE.
TAKE A LOOK.
[ALL CHANTING]
>> [BLEEP] JOE BIDEN!
>> Sean: AND THAT IS NOT THE
ONLY ANTI-BIDEN CHANT OF THAT IS
TRENDING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
LET'S GO BRANDED, THAT IS
ANOTHER FAVORITE AMONG AMERICANS
BECAUSE OF THIS SPECIAL MOMENT
ON NBC OF A NASCAR DRIVER
WINNING A BIG RACE, BRANDON
BROWN AFTER HIS BIG VICTORY AT
TALLADEGA REPORT ACTUALLY THINKS
THEY ARE CHEERING BRANDON BUT
WHEN YOU LISTEN CLOSELY, NO,
THEY ARE NOT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SUCH AN UNBELIEVABLE MOMENT.
>> BRANDON, YOU ALSO TOLD ME --
AS YOU CAN HIT THE CHANTS FROM
THE CROWD.
>> [BLEEP] >> "LET'S GO
BRANDON."
>> Sean: THEY WERE NOT
CHANTING LET'S GO BRANDON AT
ALL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE ANGRY AT JOE BIDEN,
THE WORLD IS PAYING THE PRICE.
INFLATION, IN OTHER WORDS, THAT
IS A $2,100 ANNUAL TAX ON EVERY
SINGLE HOUSEHOLD IN THE COUNTRY
REGARDLESS OF INCOME.
COMPLIMENTS OF JOE BIDEN
TERRIFIC ECONOMIC POLICIES.
THE COST OF EGGS, MEAT, POULTRY
FISH IS UP 20%, ON TOP OF MEAT
AND PROCESSED MEAT, GUESS WHAT,
A PREDICTOR THAT STEAK WILL NOW
BECOME A CHAMPAGNE-LIKE LUXURY
ONLY AVAILABLE TO THE WEALTHY
AND THE CEO OF KRAFT HEINZ ARE
WARNING THAT RISING FOOD PRICES
ARE NOT GOING AWAY.
MEANWHILE, LOOK AT THIS, THE
COST OF COTTON IS UP A WHOPPING
47% TO DATE.
THAT IS A 10-YEAR HIGH.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A 30-YEAR HIGH
IN TERMS OF INFLATION
INDICATORS.
IN OTHER WORDS ANY CLOTHING YOU
BUY THAT HAS GOTTEN IN IT OR
PLAN ON BUYING IS GOING TO COST
A LOT MORE.
THE COST OF RAW MATERIALS ALSO
SURGING.
THE COST OF MOTOR VEHICLES, CAR
PARTS IS SURGING.
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE THING YOU
BUY IS NOW MORE EXPENSIVE.
AT THE CORE OF ALL OF THIS,
MASSIVE INFLATION, RISING ENERGY
COSTS AND GAS PRICES, ALL CAUSED
BY JOE BIDEN AND ONE OF HIS
FIRST ACTS AS
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN ARTIFICIALLY
PRODUCED AMERICA'S OIL AND GAS
SUPPLY CAPABILITIES AND AT THE
SAME TIME, HE LITERALLY LOWERED
THE SUPPLY CHAIN OF THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD'S
ECONOMY, ENERGY, IN THE STROKE
OF ONE PEN.
HE HALTED THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE
AND HE GAVE A VLADIMIR PUTIN,
YES, SPECIAL WAIVER TO BUILD HIS
PIPELINE.
AS A RESULT, NATURAL GAS PRICES
ARE UP A WHOPPING 112% SINCE
JANUARY.
BIDEN IS MAKING RUSSIA RICH
AGAIN.
OIL PRICES ARE UP 65%.
$5 A GALLON GASOLINE IS NOW A
REALITY NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA,
AND SOON PROBABLY A GAS STATION
NEAR YOU.
OF COURSE, DIESEL PRICES, THEY
ARE ALSO SURGING.
EVERYTHING YOU BUY IN EVERY
STORE GETS THERE VIA TRUCK.
THOSE TRUCKS, THEY USE DIESEL.
THESE EXTRA TRANSPORTATION
COSTS, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PASSED ON TO YOU.
PART OF THE BIDEN INFLATION TAX,
THE CONSUMER.
ADD TO THIS ANOTHER MAJOR
PROBLEM, AMERICA'S SUPPLY CHAIN
IS IN A STATE OF CHAOS BECAUSE
AMERICA'S WORKERS SHORTAGE,
CARGO SHIPS OFF THE COAST IN
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, THEY ARE
PILING UP, UNABLE TO UNLOAD
THEIR CONTAINERS.
MEANWHILE, GOODS ARE NOW PILING
UP IN WAREHOUSES BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF DRIVERS.
NOW NATIONWIDE SHORTAGES HAVE
BECOME THE NORM.
AT WALMART, COSTCO, RATIONING
TOILET PAPER.
TIRES ARE BECOMING HARD TO FIND
FOR YOUR CAR OR TRUCK.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN,
GROCERY STORE SHELVES ARE
BECOMING EMPTY IN SOME PLACES
FOR THOSE IMAGES FROM TENNESSEE.
ECONOMISTS ARE WARNING MANY
CHRISTMAS PRESENTS FOR YOUR KIDS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ARRIVING IN
TIME FOR THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
EVEN MORE TROUBLING, LOOMING
SHORTAGE OF SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS.
ONE TRANSPORTATION EXPERT IS NOW
PREDICTING THIS DRIVER SHORTAGE
ALONE WILL REMAIN SEVERE ALL
YEAR LONG.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THE ECONOMY,
ANOTHER BIDEN PREVENTABLE
CATASTROPHE.
YET JOE BIDEN AND FELLOW
DEMOCRATS ARE DETERMINED TO MAKE
IT WORSE AND WORSE WITH
TRILLIONS IN NEW SPENDING AND
NEW TAXES THAT WILL BE PASSED ON
TO YOU.
THAT IS A MOVE THAT WILL CAUSE
INFLATION TO SKYROCKET EVEN
MORE.
AS JEN PSAKI EXPLAINED EARLIER
TODAY, DEMOCRATS NEVER LET A
CRISIS GO TO WASTE.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
MAKE FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE IN HIS
ECONOMY AND HE THINKS COMING OUS
EXACTLY THE
TIME TO DO THAT AND IF WE DON'T
DO IT NOW, IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
THE COST OF CHILD CARE TO GO
BACK TO JOSH'S QUESTION EARLIER,
IF WE DON'T ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS, IF WE DON'T WANT TO
ENSURE THAT UNIVERSAL PRE-K IS A
REALITY NOW, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO DO
IT FOR SOME TIME.
>> Sean: HOPEFULLY YOU GET
VOTED OUT IN THE MIDTERMS.
ANYWAY, SADLY THE NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALIST SPENDING PROGRAMS,
THAT IS WHAT YOU NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT AND WE CANNOT AFFORD THE
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS THEY ARE
GOING TO BORROW AND SPEND.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN CALIFORNIA IS
BANNING GAS POWERED LAWN MOWERS
AND CHAINSAWS IN CALIFORNIA.
I HOPE THEY DON'T DO THAT TO
WEED RECORDS.
I LOVE MY WEED WACKER.
IN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OF
RESPA'S NEW VACCINE MANDATES ARE
FORCING THOUSANDS OF TEACHERS,
POLICE OFFICERS,
FIRST RESPONDERS, HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND YES, OUR
MILITARY ARE OPTING OUT OF THEIR
JOBS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
A NATIONWIDE WORKER SHORTAGE ON
TOP OF IT.
ONE POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT, A
FEDERAL JUDGE RULED IN FAVOR OF
MEDICAL WORKERS SEEKING
RELIGIOUS EXCEPTION TO THE
VACCINE MANDATE.
AIRLINES WERE FORCED TO CANCEL
MORE THAN 1,000 FLIGHTS BECAUSE
OF A SUSPECTED SICK-OUT PROTEST
AGAINST THE COMPANY'S NEW
VACCINE MANDATE, AND THAT IS NOT
STOPPING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WERE THE GREAT
FLIP-FLOP, I'VE BEEN WRONG ON
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING
DR. FAUCI.
YOU KNOW, THE GUY WHO HELPED
FUND THE WUHAN VIROLOGY LAB, FOR
FLOATING A TRULY INSANE MANDATE
FOR ALL AMERICANS WANT TO FIND A
COMMERCIAL AIRLINE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE A VACCINE
MANDATE FOR TRAVEL IN EFFECT FOR
THE HOLIDAYS?
>> WELL, IT DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU
MEAN.
WE DO NOW HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
PEOPLE COMING IN FROM OUTSIDE
THE COUNTRY, WE ARE NOT
UNITED STATES CITIZENS.
THEY REALLY MUST BE QUIET, THEY
GET VACCINATED AS WELL AS
GETTING TESTED BEFORE.
ON THE TABLE IS THE ISSUE OF
MANDATES FOR VACCINES.
AS ALWAYS DISCUSSED, WE ALWAYS
WIND UP DISCUSSING --
>> DO YOU SUPPORT IT?
>> I DON'T WANT TO SAY SUPPORT
OR NOT.
I THINK IT'S A DECISION THAT IS
MADE FROM INPUT FROM A NUMBER OF
PARTS OF THE GOVERNMENT
INCLUDING PUBLIC HEALTH.
>> Sean: SOON IF JOE BIDEN
GETS HIS WAY, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
GET A JOB OR EVEN TRAVEL BUT
DON'T WORRY, I'M SURE THAT THEY
WILL HAVE NO IMPACT ON OUR
ALREADY STRUGGLING ECONOMY,
RIGHT?
AT THE CENTER OF OUR CURRENT
ECONOMIC CRISIS, THERE HE IS,
THE WEAK, FRAIL, COGNITIVELY
STRUGGLING MASS, CLUELESS
JOE BIDEN EXPERIENCING EVEN MORE
COGNITIVE DECLINE TODAY.
ANOTHER 3:00 P.M. EARLY
AFTERNOON LATE.
HE NEEDED HIS NAPPY TIME, AND
WHILE HE IS ASLEEP AT THE WHEEL
HIS RADICAL ADVISORS TAKE OVER.
WHO THEY ARE WEED OUT KNOW AND
THEY WANT TO RUN TO MENTALLY
COUNTRY AND THEY ARE SAYING
SO.
THE GREATEST ECONOMIC ENGINE ON
THE FACE OF THIS EARTH, THE
GREATEST WEALTH CREATING SYSTEM
ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH, AND
ONE OPEN BORDERS, THEY WANT
AMNESTY, WOMB TO THE TOMB,
CRADLE TO THE GRAVE
ENTITLEMENTS.
WE CANNOT AFFORD FOR EVERY
SINGLE PERSON UNABLE OR
UNWILLING TO WORK.
THEY WANT TO TURN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA INTO
THEIR